[Musica]
signore e signori buonasera qua ci deve
essere un problema audio per chirico
buonasera loro non dicono niente nel suo
entusiasmo se tali facciamo un attimo
facciamo finta che sono appena entrato
quindi un po di entusiasmo so che è
tardi
signore e signori buonasera grazie
quanti ringrazio te che stai applaudendo
tantissimo guarda veramente io parlo con
te parlo con te ma è come se si parlando
con ognuno di voi ok semplicissimo tra
l'altro c'è la maglietta fluorescente
fantastica guardatelo guardatelo
guardate e incredibile veramente a te
provo parlo direttamente con te quando
qualcuno ti fa buonasera di solito tu
rispondi buona sanità bisogna vedere
l'ultimo al tiro buonasera voi solo
buonasera così e poi iniziamo
signore e signori buonasera a parte
qualche ubriaco in giro però io non sono
alina babooska sono alex russo
qua c'è l'applauso e applauso qua in
questo una cosa incredibile hanno
sbagliato proprio l'agenzia ha sbagliato
per la fretta mi ha messo a lina
babooska fortunatamente fluxus mai fatto
partire lo stesso
vedrete che le dimensioni non contano
me lo diceva sempre la mia ex fidanzata
belle signore e signori sono venuto qui
oggi per raccontarvi la mia verità
signore e signori da 28 anni soffro di
una malattia molto grave
ho provato pure sperimentali massaggi
terapie strane ma niente i medici dicono
che non c'è nulla non c'è nulla da fare
signore e signori
signore e signori signore e signori sono
eterosessuale
sì amo le donne alte more bionde tutte
sia quelli delle ginocchia punta con i
piedi sotto la cella simpaty antipatiche
ricchio morte di fame
signor andrea detto anche con una forma
di parmigiano se questa avesse le gambe
sì per esempio lei per me lo sai che è
bellissima
leggo anno scusa sei un uomo scusa mi
scusi scusi
scusate è che da quando ho perso lei ho
perso la testa cioè prima avevo perso la
testa per lei
e adesso che non ho più lei ho perso la
testa perché non ho più lei prima avevo
perso la testa per lei e adesso che
erano più lei mi sembrava chiaro
anna si chiamava la proposizione delle
anna in sala
alzate la mano le hanno in sala non ci
sono hanno in sala
certo perché le mandavo fuori l'avete
fatto apposta ma anche arianna marianna
giovanna fuori
no no vabbè rimanete rimanete anche
perché no è colpa vostra
e poi si sa come vanno queste cose no il
giorno prima eravamo insieme a brindare
sul balcone davanti il mare la luna le
stelle se l'amore della mia vita come te
nessuno mai
staremo per sempre insieme
cazzate
perché tre giorni dopo sempre sul
balcone davanti il mare la luna le
stelle non sono abbastanza per te ti
meriti una donna migliore
e siccome ti voglio troppo bene ti
lascio come mi lasci mi vuoi troppo bene
mi lasci allora io l'ho detto tu hai un
altro sì mi ha detto sì e mi ritrovo qui
oggi insieme a voi
che culo a comunque però l'ho presa
benissimo chi ci pensa più a lanna e poi
vi dico una cosa in confidenza glielo
dico dopo una settimana avevo già la
fila di donne e questo mi ha fatto
riflettere ma perché stare con una donna
soltanto quando ogni donna può regalarti
qualcosa di unico e speciale
costanza 30 anni fotomodella sono una
cosa da costanza perché con costanza che
ci pensa più anno chissà quanto tempo
sarà passato poi a membro sarà passato
cinque anni 4 mesi 3 settimane 15 giorni
27 ore 15 minuti 12 secondi 15 secondi
sei secondi 17 secondi ci sono delle
coppie in sala non vi vergognate non mi
mandate ma non vi vergognate
cioè le coppie già della mano e volevo
darvi un consiglio proprio non brindare
sui balconi che porta una sfiga
ve lo dico la verità ho comunque signori
cambiamo discorso che è meglio vi
presento la mia fidanzata perfetta non
parla la suoni quando voi non ha mai mal
di testa al massimo giù di corda
ma questa taglia posta dai signori in
pochissimo tempo abbiamo già fatto
grandi cose
grazie a lei sono riuscito a ritrovare
il mio equilibrio grazie a lei sono
riuscito a ritrovare la mia serenità
grazie a lei sono uscito a scordarmi di
quella donna che mi ha rovinato la vita
anna anna che ci pensa più anna pan anna
anna dimmi perché ancora io penso a te
ne ho tante cose da fare ma non ti ho
mai smesso di amare ti penso quando vado
al mare mentre teresa non si fa pregare
ti penso quando vado in banca mentre
francesca non va la santa ti penso
quando vado il giardino mentre luisa mi
guarda da vicino ti penso proprio sul
finale e all'improvviso la tua faccia mi
appare e indovina lo fa masciare e tutte
le donne mi mandano a cagare
[Musica]
dimmi perché dimmi perché dimmi perché
devono soffrire lo so conte era diverso
era il mio cuore che faceva sesso
lo so conterà più belle ma tu non ci sei
e non posso tagliarmi quindi se tu non
ci sei non puoi pretendere che io
diventi gay e quindi visto che tu non ci
sei più a led bene porto almeno 6
francesca teresa luisa gelsomina franca
è al posto suo l'è sentita al suo posto
su costanza costanzi si sono sei si sono
sei si sono sei ma arriverò a 106 lo so
potrei sembrare un porco ma io volevo
solo il tuo corpo e lo volevo tutto per
me ma tu non sei mia e lo devo ammettere
a se tu questa è ancora con me
dati aspetto vienimi a prendere
ma se tu puoi stare ancora come dai ti
aspetto vienimi a prendere vieni da
[Musica]
vieni da me
tienimi apprende vieni da
vieni da
vieni da me vienimi a prendere vieni da
[Musica]
[Applauso]
secondo voi sta arrivando
sapete ho provato in tutti i modi a
riconquistarla anche così non è bastato
ma dovrebbe partire della musica
[Musica]
chi
grazie
grazie davvero almeno conquistato voi e
poi proprio l'altra volta è successo
proprio la stessa identica cosa un po
diversa ma un signore sulla cinquantina
il sulla cinquantina è venuto proprio da
me alla fine del mio spettacolo di
strada perché sono anche un artista di
strada ma detto bravissimo ma se un
fenomeno ma che lavoro fai
è una cosa abbastanza frequente però
quel giorno ero e cerco sempre di essere
gentile come diceva prima cristina ma e
quindi ho cercato di mantenere la calma
allora gli ho detto questo è il mio
lavoro ma che c'entra non è che a 50
anni puoi fare questo lavoro sia 50 ti
vorrei fare questo lavoro ma che c'entra
e se ti rompi una gamba se mi rompo una
gamba vuol dire canterò il suo nero
soltanto e se ti rompi un braccio sembra
un buon braccio vuol dire che canterò
soltanto va bene e se ti tagli la lingua
guardate lo dico adesso che c'è la
lingua tutta intera
[ __ ] scusate ma
e finali andato bene perché ho detto ok
almeno sfogato la mia nota mia alla mia
rabbia e frustrazione sono tornata a
casa però ancora le sue parole
dentro di me erano veramente forti e non
riuscivo a dormire però mi sono fatto
un'unica e semplice domanda e ho
ritrovato la pace
se io domani dovessi morire
sarei felice della mia vita le ho detto
sì è nato questo pezzo
impronte
[Musica]
poiché mi giudicate proprio voi con le
scarpe firmate parlo con voi che vi
accontentate
io invece no
corro contro vento
faccio quello che sento
[Musica]
e tu vediamo se ci riesci se sei capace
di fare nella vita quello che ti piace
spezza le catene
e ricorda di volerti bene vediamo se ci
riesce se sei capace di fare nella vita
quello che ti piace di un aver paura
della tua natura
china nonna
ma la nanna
anna
a tempo con le mani vai
[Applauso]
e poi guardandomi ancora ma guardandomi
negli occhi
pensiamo a giocare facciamo gli shock e
non pensavamo all'apparenza che crea
diffidenza
guardatevi ancora quando tante mira gli
occhi non pensiamo a giocare
facciamo gli shock e non pensiamo all
apparenza
e crea solo diffide
senza diffidenza
diffidenza
ma c'è per tutti una speranza
no no
[Musica]
[Applauso]
e poi togliamoci le scarpe
mettiamo da parte e seguendo l'orizzonte
lasciamo le nostre impronte
[Musica]
grazie
signori grazie a tutti io sono a lina bo
bosco è sono alex russo
grazie
[Applauso]